and lebron clears it away
lakers down 11. lebron a spin lebron
with a finish
wow signature move dominique kind of
spin like this
it's just only a couple are as good as
lebron and his size his speed
and really more important his vision
because if you were to come over and
run such a willing passer cj mccollum
it's an 11-1
laker run up ahead beautiful touchdown a
13-1 laker run
this decoy in the world and we've seen
this past many times
just most notably to our boy dwayne wade
and vice versa the full court
hello so good draws the double oh
there's something i got it on the rim
unable to convert lakers have a chance
to take the lead now
down a point is fine by lebron anthony
davis sprinting down the floor good
night
as he's walking down you can't see him
right here but look at that
just just whipping it past nerf is like
my fault
and you expect lebron james to come out
in attacking mode nice pass
and davis off the green miss gabriel
sits down with the two fouls hassan
whiteside comes in
whiteside made some very big plays in
game one alley up to james
and there's anthony davis with a perfect
pass come out of the gate
side out of bounds this is a setup you
gotta see it if you're the
blazers they don't they allow a direct
dive to the cup
on point pass from anthony davis lebron
james
on a mission early in this ball game
[Applause]
davis foul count it and one not a smart
play although
mccollum was trying to get it before the
active shooting especially their biggs
running the floor good drop off pass by
caruso anthony davis rewarded
for running the floor gets the contact
and the hoop
and those are energy points to tip in
well davis is taking the lead role in
that department tonight step back
another three
got it anthony davis 29 points now
you can play either for yourself or for
your teammate
lillard guarded by caruso dribbled into
a double team anthony davis
with the steal outlet to james james
finds kuzma and kuzma off the glass
by here in the second james sets himself
for three
nails it there's caruso looking for a
teammate he's found it danny green open
shot won't fall rebound tipped howard to
davis
[Applause]
guarded now by lebron james drives into
the pain goes inside shot blocked by
davis
kuzma head out to green back to lebron
james bounce past caruso
big time blocked by anthony davis we've
seen damian lillett finish this type of
play but anthony davis protecting the
rim
at an elite level says not on my watch
anthony davis coming on a baseline
looking to
double team and carmelo unselfishly
delivers the pass
anthony davis season opening goes inside
and the
foul aggressive move from davis
russo and anthony davis in the pick and
roll
caruso sets the screen late rotation
nurkic
with the put back see how the paint just
opened up there for
lillard but at the same time now this is
what you get on the other end kept it
going that 15-0 run to start it
last three quarters for the lakers
106.76 they've outscored
the blazers they are plus 30 in the last
three quarters please check your rear
view objects
objects in your rear view mirror are
close at a triple-double and a losing
effort in game one
best scoring game in game three with 38
and he drops another three ball
the eight seated blazers right now as we
approach the one minute mark of this
first half lebron
james two opponents with 50 plus coming
to the end of this second quarter
james all the way in that has been the
theme
of the night the drives by the lakers
excellent three-point
shooting here in the first half lebron
james 22 points seven assists
80 goes for 18 points four rebounds four
assists
perform even though he is on the nba
campus well as lebron takes a deep three
oh my goodness
i just like to say this to put a button
on it well when you got a lead like this
you walk right into a 36 footer lebron
james
again portland won game one 100 to 93
it's been downhill for them ever since
a.d mid-range settles in nobody that
thought they were going to win
so they're just out there playing free
[Applause]
a d baseline for his mid-range game has
been
on point and then some
liberator put up the final shot and he
knocks it down
here's davis now hezonja zone gives it
right back marquee morris no
davis is there wrestles the offensive
rebound a two-handed jam and a foul
dear saying let me get physical old
school you can pick them
moses malone it doesn't matter king
patrick ewing get your rebound
winston on the drive and kick tucker
quarter three
and howard with the rebound
lebron lebron see it with your chest
good feed from caruso lebron running the
lane
russell westbrook trying to take the
charge grown man
move wow express yourself lebron
35 years old yeah javale we saw two
mcgee that pass was coming in a little
hot westbrook on lebron
lebron eat it up at the rim wow he got
some bounce in those 35 year old legs
and through covington county
weight room time this great this late
this is russell westbrook
folks is not on my watch and then on the
other end pushes the basketball puts his
head down
get out of my way that is back-to-back
spectacular plays lebron with that wide
base
and couldn't catch good defense by
tucker
stood his ground lebron punches that
into the family section and he's playing
with a sense of urgency
didn't have his way offensively but
didn't give up on the play which is so
crucial
we have seen james getting his first
breather anthony davis very aggressive
early goes right at
pj tucker once again using his size
count it and one
i like the way that he's aggressive this
is good defense by pj tucker but he's
going towards the hoop so he gets better
position
high percentage he was getting
compliments from other coaches hey
that's a great zone you have
he's like no no it was the man caruso up
and james down
steal one pass and an easy love
danny green with his second long
distance bomb back to 12.
that's seven assists for rondo in his
first half oh shot swatted away
tickets have scored 14 straight points
they were down by as many as 21 in the
first half
davis counted and the foul anthony davis
does on the other end
no time to mess around i'm going to
punish the smaller defender
gordon lost the handle picked up by
james back to caruso throws it up
hammer time for lebron james
i mean the steal mike bring calling for
hammer time
lakers regain the lead up four
mike d'antoni citing personal reasons
and that's all he would give
on daniel house he did say it was not
coveted related
oh anthony davis on a beautiful setup
from rondo together he just steps up
pj tucker starts to front rondo throws
it up over the top
just a beautiful pass right on the money
right over
jeff green no daniel house tonight for
houston
mclemore elevated nice pass inside to
caruso
boy lebron put it right on a dime it was
a 95 mile an hour fastball to caruso
and off the dribble going to his left
hardin
shakes lebron james and comes up short
into the hands of davis now the lakers
on the run
to lebron lebron all the way freight
train
coming lebron james lebron out on the
run he's usually the guy
leading the fast break and making the
pass but here
anthony dave and now lebron james on the
floor
covington still grabbing at his jaw it
looks like
up top for davis the second time tonight
covington has it
clock ticks down to two down to one
rivers goes strong and it's blocked by
james
covington puts it back no shot
no basket covington got it off too late
tenth of the series
in the first three games what a great
effort here staying with the play
covington follows it up but he did not
get that off
in time look at this block though wow
staying with the play
he just did not get it off the chase
down
by lebron james a great attacker
oh gordon blocked by davis pushing it
here's kuzma in the run-out
oh i want to play not just the block
then the pass
them off the three-point line harden has
not made a three yet the two makes are
macklemore and covington
rockets have just got to stop this you
cannot be
fronting leave westbrook open misses
this time dave is
baiting him into it look at this pass
and davis finishes with a foul
we have seen this all year long the jump
shooter out top
he runs out lebron james for that yeah
brings the sounds out there's a lot from
rondo to anthony davis
got to get one up quick gordon shot fake
puts it on the deck
and it's knocked away by caruso up ahead
rondo all the way lebron james throws it
down that was risky
here late in this game man this was
ill-advised good pass and james
hammers one home i would say he's okay
gets the little alley pass from caruso
and the finish
from the king rondo's six on the shot
clock
that was deflected davis again late
clock
over jokic oh he hits it
got the shot clock running down here
miscommunication at the offensive end
and
anthony davis who was seven five points
we talked about michael porter junior
the third
quarter as anthony davis my goodness
rondo was just putting on the show
boy these two wow they've got to get
some open shots for his teammates he
knows it's on him now
kuzma gives it right back lebron takes
the pass lebron with some spin
oh my goodness how did he finish that
and one lebron james
james looking like caruso on this play
right here
getting to the cup taking the contact
how about the english right there just
man pretty play looking more like
minnesota fats
lebron just probing gives it up dave is
passed up at three shot clock at one now
it's up
and it's in anthony davis with a three
the lakers a.d he says let me take it
here for lebron
you've done the rest the long step back
three
2.1 seconds remaining denver foul to
give jokic
trying to disrupt rondo he puts it in
here's davis 4-3 in the win
oh it's good anthony davis has won it
for the lakers
anthony davis
scored as a good three-point basket they
will take a look but
anthony davis davis is going to send the
lakers to a 2-0
series lead in the clutch
delivers the bomb great defense
by the nuggets just outstanding offense
by anthony davis who's made back to back
huge threes here in this fourth quarter
they confirm the basket
game over great play call by coach vogel
what he did was he put the screen on the
big fella big fellas aren't used to
coming off the screen
playing defense that's why jokers did a
great job getting the hand up but that
was plumley's man coming off the screen
lebron probing shot clock at four now
he's on the drive and he'll finish
previous move he splits the double team
and you're right chris plumley right
there
either take that not afraid to go to the
basket gives it up this time millsap
plowing his way in and morris with the
block that looked like he was on the way
down
up top for anthony davis rondo with the
pass
talked all year about them not being
able to protect big leads
like he would like them to
porter on the cut oh he's met at the rim
by davis
this lakers team oh my goodness this is
beautiful
oh meet you at the summit my friend
goodness what a [ __ ]
block shots by the lakers and that's
their playoff average
shot clock off last shot opportunity for
la
davis he'll pull the three oh davis hits
it
with one second left for another
terrific fourth
davis buries a three gives the lakers a
lead
james puts it up can't get it to go gets
his own
finds caruso he sets up davis three ball
is up
and then timeout
michael anthony
davis he hit a big three at the end of
the third
and cashes one in from the top here ten
point liquor lead
it's the most career thirty plus point
playoff games
lebron james tonight his 116th
which is number one
he'll take a three lebron james will hit
a three
oh how about it lebron
james pulling out all the daggers here
in the fourth quarter
12-point laker lead lebron has the last
nine for la tell you what lebron james
he's done it in so many ways
leave it that's what he does the follow
through you think he knows what time it
is